Hallo, guten Abend. Ich bin auch die Sestation Asthanastätich und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Aber natürlich. Wenn Sie der Arzt hier sind, dann ist das kein Problem.
Ja, natürlich bin ich Arzt.
Ja, Sie sind so jung, das weiß ich nicht.
Ich bin ein Ärzter, habe ich so sehr hingesiert.
Ja, Sie haben recht. Ich bin neuer Arzt.
Okay, wenn Sie mich nicht falsch verstehen, Doktor, würden Sie mir verraten, wie alt Sie sind?
Ich bin 32 Jahre alt.
Oh, so jung und schon Arzt, das ist aber schön. Toll.
Ja. Bevor wir über Ihre Bescheidung sprechen, muss ich Sie um persönliche Daten bitten.
Zum Beispiel, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Monika Rütters.
Monika Rütters. Können Sie Ihr Name und Nachname buchstabieren?
Monika, M-O-N, Ida, C-Sah, Anton, Monika.
Rütters, wenn man es spricht, R-U, Doppeltee, Emil, Richard, Siegfried, Rütters.
Rütters, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 46 Jahre alt.
46, und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 23. April, 1979.
79. In dieser Monat gibt es Ihre Geburtstatemier.
Genau.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,72 m.
72, und wissen Sie Ihre aktuelle Gewicht?
Ja, ich war heute Morgen auf der Waage, das sind 85 kg.
85, ok. Können wir Ihre Bescheidung anfangen?
Welche Bescheidung haben Sie? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Herr Dr., das ist ganz schlimm.
Ich habe schon seit einer Woche etwas Rückenschmerzen, aber ich dachte, das geht wieder weg, weil das habe ich immer wieder.
Wie sind Sie? Ich sitze im Büro und habe eine sitzende Tätigkeit.
Aber seit gestern Abend ist das Akut ganz schlimm geworden, das ist wie eine Blockade.
Zwischen den Schulterblättern ist es ein ganz starker Schmerz.
Ich konnte heute Nacht nicht schlafen, obwohl ich Tabletten genommen habe.
Was haben Sie angenommen?
Ich habe zu Hause Evo Profen gehabt, und habe mir 2 Tabletten Evo Profen genommen.
2 Tabletten? Wahrscheinlich 400 mg?
Ich glaube, das, was man ohne Rezept aus der Apotheke bekommt.
Wie stark die Schmerzen auf einer Schale 1 bis 3?
Heute Nacht war es ganz schlimm, jetzt ist es ein bisschen besser, aber immer noch sehr schlimm.
Deswegen bin ich ja auch gekommen.
Ich würde sagen, 8, 9.
Brauchen Sie momentan eine Schmerz mit den?
Das wäre ganz toll, wenn Sie etwas haben, das hilft.
Da wäre ich Ihnen sehr dankbar.
Bevor ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel gebe, muss ich ein paar Fragen stellen.
Zum Beispiel, ist Ihnen allergie bekannt?
Nein, bisher habe ich keine allergie gehabt.
Leiden Sie an Kuronschenerkrankungen, Nieren insuffizieens oder Leber insuffizieens?
Nein, bisher ist nichts bekannt.
Dann rufe ich die Krankenkanzler und Sie bringen so schnell wie möglich die Medikamente.
Kannst du es wohlfühlen, können wir vorsetzen?
Ja, ich glaube, wir können weitermachen.
Können Sie die Messen beschreiben?
Er hat dumpfstechend, ziehend?
Ich würde sagen, es ist stechend und ziehend.
Ich kann meinen Arm links nicht mehr anheben, ganz schwach.
Ich zeige es noch mit dem anderen Arm.
Es ist hinten am linken Schulterblatt, wie eine Faust.
Es ist ganz schnell gestrahlt in den linken Arm aus.
Ich kann mich nicht hinlegen, richtig sitzen.
Der Arm ist extrem schmerzhaft.
Ich zahle die Schmerzen in andere Körperregionen?
Ja, in den Nacken, in den Schultern.
Nacken, unter.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten?
Seit einer Woche habe ich ein bisschen Rückenschmerzen.
Ich dachte, das ist eine Muskelverspannung.
Aber heute Nacht ist es akut schlimm.
Von einer Stunde bis nachher ist es ganz schlimm.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, dass die Auslöser sind?
Nein, ich saß auf dem Stuhl und dann ist es relativ schnell schlimm geworden.
Etwas hochheben zum Beispiel?
Nein, ich war zu Hause, habe nichts gemacht.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass sich verschlimmert ist.
Auf der linken Seite kann ich mich gar nicht liegen.
Ich versuche extrem wenig auf die rechte Seite, aber da kann ich nicht lange liegen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich bewegen soll.
Im Sitz kann ich ein bisschen schlafen, aber das war auch kompendlich.
Sind die Schmerzen anfällig oder immer da?
Ja, die kommen so wellenartig.
Aber eigentlich fast immer, muss ich sagen.
Die Schmerzen sind immer da, aber dann gibt es Phasen, da ist es noch schlimmer.
Dann gibt es Phasen, da wird es ein bisschen besser.
Haben Sie einen Traubasgefühl oder Muskeln schwer bemerkt?
Ich merke, dass das brennt in den Arm ein bisschen, den Fingerspitzen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, wenn ich jetzt eine Tasse hochhebe, geht es gar nicht.
Es ist kribbelt, wie Armeisen laufen.
Hatten Sie Unfall oder Verletzung?
Nein.
Leiden Sie unter Hörstörung oder Sechstörung oder Ohrensausen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Es freut mich, dass Sie nicht so Probleme haben.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Was haben Sie gemeint?
Schmerzen, Schmerzen, Schmerzen.
Es freut mich.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbruch?
Durch die Schmerzen habe ich leicht Übelkeit.
Wahrscheinlich auch durch Medikamente, aber erbrochen habe ich nicht.
Super.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, eigentlich immer gleich geblieben.
Leiden Sie unter unwirkliche Wassalassen oder Sturrgang?
Was meint ihr mit unwirkürlich?
Unwirkuliche Wassalassen.
Du wirst nicht öfters auf Toilette? Nein.
Ein Sturrgang-Problem habe ich auch nicht.
Super.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Zu gut, das ist ja mein Problem.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie keine chronischen Erkrankungen leiden.
Und wahrscheinlich nehmen Sie keine regelmäßigen Medikamente ein?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, die Dagenglase hat man mir entfernt vor 5-8 Jahren.
Ich hatte eine Entzündung und danach hat man das entfernt.
Wegen der Internetverwaltung konnte ich nicht gut gehört.
Wie viele Jahre?
Ungefähr 8 Jahre.
War die Operation komplikationlos?
Ich glaube, keine Probleme.
Ich konnte relativ schnell wieder nach Hause.
Seitdem ist alles in Ordnung.
Sonst noch etwas?
Nur eine Entfernung.
Das reicht auch.
Sind Sie gegen Kinderkrankheit verständlich geimpft?
Ich denke schon, mein Hausarzt überprüft immer die Impfungen.
Er sagt, das war alles in Ordnung.
Super.
Wann war Ihr letzter Reise?
Wie? Was war eine Reise?
Vor 2 Jahren war ich in Griechenland.
Vor 2 Jahren?
Und Frau Roth hat es bei ihr als Frau regelmäßig?
Nein, ich gehe sehr ungern zum Arzt.
Das ist auch schon ein Geherr, dass ich beim Frauenarzt war.
Ich habe bisher nicht Probleme gehabt.
Ich weiß aber, um die Diagnose festzustellen,
ich lege Ihnen, dass Sie...
Welche Diagnose?
Mamaria oder Brustprobleme?
Ich habe bisher keine Probleme.
Alles gut.
Ich lege Ihnen, dass Sie regelmäßig Frauenarzt besuchen.
Ich überleg es mir.
Wann war Ihr letzter Reise?
Das ist auch völlig in Ordnung.
Das war für ungefähr 2 Wochen.
Wie ist Ihre Eltern?
Sie sind noch gesund?
Mein Vater hat ein bisschen Bluthochdruck.
Er nimmt Medikamente, ist aber gut eingestellt.
Meine Mutter ist sehr sportlich.
Er hat kleine Tabletten.
Wie alt ist Ihr Eltern?
Meine Mutter ist circa 68.
Mein Vater ist 71.
Sind Sie ein Zeitkind?
Ja.
Sie arbeiten im Büro.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Sekretärin.
Ich bin in einer Firma Chefassistentin.
Chefassistentin, super.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, und ich habe eine Tochter.
Ist Sie gesund?
Ja, wirklich.
Sind Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Ja, natürlich.
Was ist das für eine Sekretärin?
Ich rauche ganz normalen Sekretten.
Wie oft und seit wann?
Seit dem Studium eigentlich.
Seit 23 Jahren.
Ich bin 20 Jahre alt.
Ich habe ungefähr eine halbe Schachtel am Tag.
Halbe Schachtel, okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ab und zu.
Was meinen Sie mit ab und zu?
Manche sagen einmal pro.
Manche sagen am Wochenende oder manchmal zum Abendessen.
Zum Angleschen Wein, das mag ich sehr gerne.
Ein bisschen Wein, okay.
Aber Sie kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Was, Drogen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Es freut mich.
Frau Ruthas, ich weiß, manche Fragen ist nie...
Sie denken, wahrscheinlich, manche Fragen sind nicht notwendig.
Aber wir müssen alle Fragen, nein,
wir müssen alle Infos sammeln, um die richtige Diagnose festzustellen.
Und ich habe meine alle Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ich glaube, Sie haben schon viel zu viel gefragt.
Ich möchte gerne wissen, was es ist.
Durch die Tablette ist es auch etwas besser geworden.
Aber ich habe einfach Angst, dass es etwas Schlimmes sein könnte.
Deswegen bin ich heute zu Ihnen gekommen, dass Sie mir helfen können.
Bisher haben wir nur das Aufnahmegespräch geführt.
Aber die anamästischen Angaben deuten am Herstern auf funktionelle
Symptome, die sich in den Arm kreben.
Sie haben sich sehr stark geschmissen.
Bewegungsprobleme.
Und bis...
Was macht man da?
Australien.
Machen Sie noch einen Röntgen?
Ja, so als werde ich körperlich untersuchen.
Dann Brutuntersuchung.
Und natürlich als operativ untersuchen würde ich Röntgen durchführen.
Röntgen, Hassröntgen.
Aber ich habe etwas vergessen.
Leiden Sie Atemnot,
Brustschimmersen, Herzblasen oder...
Das habe ich alles.
Okay, super. Es freut mich.
Und momentan habe ich alle Fragen geschworen.
Und als nächstes Schritt werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen Brut abnehmen.
Okay, dann freue ich mich.
Bitte beeilen Sie sich, weil die Schmerzen werden jetzt wieder schlimmer.
Danke schön für Ihre Verständnis.
Vielen Dank, Sie sind sehr nett, sehr freundlich.
Sie sind auch sehr nett und freundlich.
Dankeschön.
Hat jemand noch Fragen für unsere Patientin?
Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen.
Im Hinterkopf tut es weh, das stimmt.
Keine Fragen, keine Traut.
Woher spüren Sie diese Krippen genau?
Hier am Arm, bis zum Finger, bis zum Finger.
Ganz sehr viel, oder?
Ja, die ersten drei Finger sind mehr.
Die anderen auch, aber hier die ersten drei Finger.
Ich habe noch mehr, da ist es verstärkt.
Danke schön.
Hallo, guten Tag, IPEC ist mein Name, ich bin der neue Assistent-Arzt.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde Sie Ihnen vorstellen.
Darf ich?
Aber natürlich, ich habe schon gehört, dass wir einen neuen Arzt haben.
Sie haben sich noch gar nicht bei mir vorgestellt.
Wie heißen Sie bitte noch mal?
IPEC, was bedeutet IPEC?
IPEC ist ein Material.
Es bedeutet, sie im...
Ich glaube, das heißt Seite, glaube ich.
Seite, ja Seite.
Ein bisschen türkisch, kann ich auch.
Waren Sie schon in der Türkei?
Ja, ich war sehr oft in der Türkei,
ein sehr schönes Land.
Ich glaube, es gibt in Bursa sehr schöne IPEC.
Ich glaube, das ist die Hauptstadt von Seite.
Entschuldigung?
Das ist die Hauptstadt für Seite.
Ja, in der Türkei, ja.
Ja, stimmt.
Also, Herr IPEC, was haben Sie denn?
Frau Monika Lothas ist 46-jährige Patientin.
Ein Meter 72,
groß und 85 kg schwer.
Sie stellte sich
heute seit einer Woche
bestehenden,
progressierten,
persisterenden, nacken Schmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzen seien plus sich aufgetreten
und besonders seit einigen Tagen,
seit einem Tag,
sich verschlimmert.
Aber sich seit einem Tag verschlimmert.
Wo ist der Schmerz genau?
Haben Sie gesagt, im Nacken?
Im Nacken, ein bisschen linksseitig.
Oder zwischen den Schulterblättern?
Schulterblättern, ja.
Alles klar.
Ja, das ist der Schmerz.
Okay, alles klar.
Die Patientin ordnet die Schmerzen
auf einer Schmerzkalauffon-ISBC
bei 8, 9 ein.
Die Patientin beschreibt,
die Schmerzen als stehend
und die Fragen nach
Auslöser wurde verneint
Verschlimmen,
Schlimmenungsfaktor
wurde mit
hinlegen bejaht.
Auslöser.
Was haben Sie gesagt?
Was wurde bejaht?
Schlimmen
stärken
Verschlimmenungfaktor.
Ach so, das heißt,
die Verschlimmerung ist beim Liegen verstärkt.
Ja.
Und außerdem
halten die Patientin,
dass sie beim Sitzen
nur beim Sitzen
schlafen können.
Die Fragen nach
extra süßdol
in Taşukardie
angene Faktoris
und Atemnot wurden verneint.
Und sie leiden
unter
Hypostesi
und
linksseitige
Muskelschwehe
außerdem die Patientin
leider unter
und unter
und unter.
Unanfällig.
Ja, unanfällig.
An Vorerkrankungen sei keine Bekannt und die Patienten nehmen keine Medikamente ein.
An Operationen sei kolesistiktonisch für acht Jahre bekannt.
Die Operation sei ohne Komplikation verlauft.
Verlauft?
Verlauft, wie ich das sage.
Beide Patienten sind keine Allergie bekannt.
Die Familienanwohner sind vaterlisch, arterielle, hypertonisch und mutterlich nicht bekannt.
Sie sind die Sekretärin, Chefassistentin.
Sie sind verheiratet und wohnen mit ihrer Familie.
Sie haben eine gesunde Tochter.
Sie riecht seit 20 Jahren, halb- und schachtel pro Tag.
Es ist ungefähr 13-Jährige.
Bekirst, okay.
Sie trinken Anglaswein am Wochenende und ab und zu nach dem Abendessen.
Sie haben keine Kontakt mit dem Drogen.
Die anamnestischen Angaben deuten am erstes auf funktionelle Hasbiberl-Säule-Syndrome hin.
Also ein HWS-Syndrome, okay.
Ja, HWS-Syndrome.
Die finanziellen Diagnostik kommen Verletzung, akut Koronä-Syndrome und...
Was war eine Verletzung?
Verletzung, Unfall oder...?
Aber Sie haben doch gesagt, Sie haben keinen Traum.
Ja, deswegen, ich dachte so.
Und danach habe ich gefragt und die Patientin wurde verneint.
Und die Patientin hat es verneint?
Ja, hat es verneint.
Also, eine Verletzung kommt dann eher nicht in Frage.
Entschuldigung?
Eine Verletzung kommt eher nicht in Frage.
Sie hat Trauma.
Nicht hingefallen, sie hat nichts gemacht.
Also eine Verletzung hat meistens nach Englischen Traumata.
Also, das hat sie ja nicht.
Sie haben gesagt, HWS-Syndrome ist Ihre Arbeitsdiagnose.
Und was kommt sonst noch in Frage?
Schipnaikanastenos und Osteokontros und akut Koronä-Syndrome,
oder in Betracht.
Wenn Sie akut Koronasyndrom sagen, Woran denken Sie denn?
Das ist hier mehr am Rückgang.
Ja, die Schmerzen bei der akut Koronä-Syndrome
kann die Schmerzen vom Kiva bis Nabel sein, umlikus sein.
Sie hat ja Rückkönchenmärzen.
Ja.
Was vom Herz?
Es kann atürkische sein und außer dem, die Patientin habe Kribbeln geführt.
Im Linken.
Ja, das heißt, ich möchte nur wissen,
welche Seite des Herzens kann solche Beschwerden machen.
Achso.
Welche Seite vom Herzen kann solche Rückkönchmerzen machen?
Ja, links Seite geht nicht mehr.
Die Kollegin hat es gerade ihm gesagt.
Ha, ich hinterwarte Infarkten.
Also, man muss an eine Hinterwarte infarktenken, richtig.
Okay.
Woran denken Sie noch?
Weitere Differenzialdiagnose.
Vorhin kam es im Chat.
Neben der Spinalkanachelose.
Woran muss man noch denken?
An eine Aortendisektion, natürlich.
Hören Sie mich?
Ja, ich höre.
Also, weitere Differenzialdiagnose ist Aortendisektion.
Okay.
Aortendisektion.
Ja, klar.
Woran denkt man noch?
Meine Differenzialdiagnose sind 7.
Okay.
Dann tragen wir die Kollegen.
Ja.
Die Kollegen.
Sie haben das vorhin schon ein bisschen angedeutet,
aber was kann noch sein?
Jemand hat Muskelverspannung geschrieben.
Muskelverspannung, okay.
Was gibt es noch?
Arthrose.
Von die Lulis Thesis.
Jawohl.
Spondylistesis.
Okay.
Oder ganz einfach einen Bandscheinvorfall, oder?
Ah, ja.
Bandscheinvorfall.
Genau.
Ein Cerebikalabandscheinvorfall kann sein.
Oder ein Turacalabandscheinvorfall.
Turacalabandscheinvorfall kann vorwürfen sein.
Okay.
Was kann an den Wirbelkörpern noch sein?
Entschuldigung?
Was kann an den Wirbelkörper, was kann da vorliegen,
dass solche Schmerzen auslöst?
Als Auslöser kann etwas schwerer etwas herheben.
Ja, das macht ja meistens ein Muskelverspannung
oder Bandscheinvorfall.
Aber ich spreche jetzt von Wirbelkörper.
Mit keinem Orthopäden.
Verletzung.
Was war eine Verletzung?
Wir haben gesagt, sie hat kein Trauma.
Also das kann sonst noch sein.
Tumorin kann sein.
Genau.
Also eine Wirbelkörperfraktur.
Eine Impressionsfraktur.
Zum Beispiel bei einem metastasierten Karzinom.
An welcher Tumore denkt man,
was metastasiert gerne in den Knochen?
Magenkrebs.
Genau, was noch?
Lungenkrebs.
Kann auch mal sein.
Genau, was noch?
Ich hatte eine junge Patientin, die war Anfang 40.
Und sie kam mit solchen Schmerzen zu mir in die Praxis.
Und sie hatte?
Magenkrebs.
Magenkrebs kann sein, die hat ein Pankreaskarzinom.
Ja.
Und sie kam mit den ersten Symptomen,
waren diese starken Rückenschmerzen.
Und dann im CT hat man gesehen,
sie hat metastase im Wirbelkörper
und in der weiteren Suche und Staging hat man festgestellt,
dass es ein Pankreaskarzinom war.
Anfang 40.
Also die Pferenzialdiagnose.
Daran denken, Herr Doktor, Sie sind der Arzt.
Okay.
Die wahrscheinlichste Diagnose hier ist
wahrscheinlich ein Bandscheibenvorauferl.
Auf welche Höhe wäre das denn,
wenn Sie jetzt die Dermatome betrachten.
Sie hat Kribbeln, eine Kribbelparistisie,
sie hat eine muskuläre Schwäche
und die ersten drei Fingern sind kribbelig.
Genau.
Und welche Höhe ist das?
Wer weiß das? Haben wir Neurologen da?
Neurologen.
Das ist unterer HWS,
das ist C6, C7 ungefähr.
Ja.
Können Sie mal nachschauen.
Sie wissen, was Dermatome sind?
Ja.
Genau, da schauen Sie mal nach.
Zu welchem Nerv diese Symptome passen?
Momentan kann ich nicht gut erinnern.
Nein, deswegen.
Schauen Sie später nach.
Nicht jetzt, sondern später nach der Sitzung.
Das ist der Dermatome.
Beim nächsten Mal fragen wir sie nochmal.
Okay.
Jetzt habe ich sie ein bisschen verärgert.
Aber das ist eine Prüfung, sehr gut.
Ja, ich bin ein bisschen nervös.
Nervös und aufgeregt.
Aber das ist noch nicht.
Wir brauchen sie aber.